being around Kanye and Dr Dre creative
processes I've heard on each side are
insane like what was the biggest like
difference I heard Dre's a perfectionist
like a crazy perfectionist Dre is
somebody I would say that
knows where he wants to go and take time
to get there
Kanye is somebody
that takes time to get to where he
doesn't want to go don't know where you
want to go yet like the journey is the
journey free right right so he might
like the destination isn't always known
yeah like he might hear a Beat and like
for instance
I did a certain melody in a Cadence
right right and I did a rap to it he
didn't like the words but he liked the
Cadence right and then he heard a
specific beat and he only liked about
four bars of the beat
and then he took that four bars sent it
to another producer and then changed it
so you ever notice when his songs they
played for like eight bars and
introduced him like
change
that's like four or five different
producers all on one ID so he might take
one part of this beat one part of this
beat one part of this beat and figure
out way how to Mission and then do the
song on top of that and still bring in a
Mike Dean or Travis Scott or somebody
like that to take it to the next level
so with him it's just constant
creativity but Dre is like
I know where I'm going like I know how
this need to sound I know how this need
to feel I know what I want to say I know
what I want to do he takes his time to
get there but Kanye is just freelance
till we figure it out from what I've
seen wow that's dope yeah that's I mean
because both of those guys are we always
hear about the processes being so
incredible some of the greatest to ever
do it 100